the winner of the math singer has
finally
been revealed but first we're gonna take
you under the mask
for the runner-up
[Applause]
nick carter how amazing was he on this
show
when you look through the crocs jaws
you know from inside out you're really
all about here
you know you and not necessarily about
out there
and it's a comforting feeling and being
anonymous
it helps to be able to just be freeing
and just
trying things and experimenting and
playing with it and have a good time and
doing all these things that you
necessarily
wouldn't be able to do when you are an
established artist
that is you know in a band like the
backstreet boys
[Music]
oh i love this oh my god robin thicke
has been on
point with his guessing this season and
you know who else had an
inkling that the crocodile was a
backstreet boy
our very own sangeeta patel check it out
do you watch a show called masked singer
yeah i've watched it
yeah have you seen the crocodile yeah
i've seen uh
people have been saying some things but
[Laughter]
you're just watching it you're just
honestly like i'm just i'm
i haven't had a chance to really watch
much other than
okay youtube videos and yeah people
think you're the crocodile i don't know
i mean
who knows that
between secrets and lying that's what i
want to know with these shows all right
so nick was revealed as the third place
crocodile so
who was under the runner-up mushroom
costume
[Applause]
[Music]
my inspiration for being on the master
singer was to take a leap
do something different but also to
create
a moment that could be a surprise for my
family and i didn't tell them i was
coming on the show especially
i didn't tell my little daughter mandela
so
when i got the costume and i got in the
costume i
decided i would embody her spirit and
kind of flow through my movements and
everything in the way that she does when
she's
entertaining us at home
i know i love that he wanted to make
that journey special for his daughter
very cute and also
that is a very impressive costume the
whole motion thing i love it um now of
course that leaves us with the sun
who is the winner of season four but who
was under the mask
oh my
[Music]
see you gosh adjustment to the costume
was pretty
extraordinary actually i'm so sensitive
as a singer as a performer
i usually have a lot of me especially
like my throat and my head
and my abdomen my diaphragm free
i don't usually have this much weight on
me and it definitely feels like a
[Music]
compression
[Music]
so good liam rhymes
i mean it sounded like her did you guys
not think that actually sounded like her
i get so messed up on this show because
i i don't
know how you can do so much with
just sort of plug-ins and techniques
and all of this other trickery to throw
to throw you
off that i don't know what i trust on a
show like this
yeah absolutely and if you're a really
good singer you can sing in a lot of
different voices like
you could totally sound like three or
four different people if you really want
to
um i agree there's a lot of effects
there's a lot of reverbs there's a lot
of things going on
but also too the visual is so loud
that you really have to close your eyes
to be able to accurately guess some of
these voices and obviously you have to
be a music lover to know or maybe you're
a fan of a particular artist but even
for me when i'm watching
i have to close my eyes i have to really
think about it um
i with leanne rhymes i was kind of i
think it was either jojo or jordan
sparks or like a voice kind of like that
i didn't hear the classic leanne she's
got a certain uh
rasp and a little bit of a yodel in some
of her uh when her voice changes into
different octaves
she didn't do it that much in math
singer so
it would have anyway it this was great
okay are you not entertained
[Laughter]
yeah and i don't know i mean i i'm i'm
very familiar
with you know all of these everybody
who's who's on there but
when it comes right down to it i don't
actually know how familiar i
am with nick carter's voice specifically
you know what i mean like
i know who he is he's a superstar
everything else but could i pick his
specific voice
out not being a giant fan hell no
there's no way
that's a good point i just love that
these costumes were so much better than
the grinch musical
oh people are still on over there
and paul is saying uh these artists just
keep getting
better uh sarcastic klutz is saying i
knew it was land rhymes from the second
episode with her in it
i have her first cd from way back in the
day
uh and b bean is saying keisha for for
math singer
you got a fan here keisha okay come on
now
hey hey you're up there okay what do you
guys think about this yeah
saying professional singers going on the
math singer i'm silently judging
i don't know i have so much fun and the
thing that i've been getting from
a lot um like when these masks get
revealed a lot of them have said
they have been stuck at home a lot of
them are so used to going out on tour
performing in front of tons
you know thousands of people that this
was just a way for them to get out of
their house and to get up on stage
not saying that that's every season but
this season in particular
a lot of the artists who have signed on
said they just wanted to get out of the
house and perform
[Music]
yeah i think it's more i think it's more
entertaining when actual singers are on
the mat singer because
you're not supposed to know what a
football player sounds like when they
sing like how are you ever supposed to
guess that
i think the fun part of this is when it
is a leanne rimes or it is a nick carter
and you're blown away
i think it's way more entertaining to
have actual you know professional
singers on this show
because yeah yeah we don't yeah
yeah yeah you need professional singers
i know that with other celebrities that
maybe aren't singers
you know they give you all these clues
and they make it a bit of a game
but having people saying i'm sorry y'all
but if i had to watch this show and
there weren't good singers on this show
ciao i'd be like i'm good i'll just
stick to reruns of american idol gone
wrong
auditions on youtube or something but i
am not gonna watch this show if there's
not real singers but hearing
some of your favorite singers sing songs
you never thought they would hear in a
way you never thought i mean
just taking them out of their comfort
zone and especially two singers like
leanne was saying
they have a lot of rules they have a lot
of things in their writer
you know their sound checks their
equipment they have things that make
them feel comfortable because they're
like
athletes so to put them in heat in a
damn costume
anonymously singing random songs i mean
you're taking
these huge some of them are divas taking
these divas
out of their diva-like behavior and
putting them in the matrix and
it's good tv i love it it's great to see